a true progressive policy requires even
more my father got restless soul used to
say we need policies that don't just
sound good but policies that are good
and sound cries for new green movement
or hollow political rhetoric is not
combined with specific aggressive goals
and a realistic plan on how to achieve
them
and that is much easier said than done
but that my friends is the challenge for
our great state of New York to leave not
just with rhetoric but with results in a
few minutes I will sign the most
aggressive climate law in the United
States of America
[Applause]
[Music]
the New York State climate leadership
and community Protection Act requires
that we achieve a cleaner greener carbon
neutral economy the law requires that
70% of our electricity comes from
renewables by 2030 and 100% carbon free
electricity by 2040 by 2050 we will
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by an
overall 85 percent with a new climate
Council established that will offset the
remainder to make New York of 100%
carbon neutral
I want to thank all the people who work
so hard to make this bill a reality I
want to thank Vice President Al Gore and
his organization for lobbying for this
bill's passage you did the right thing
and thank you
now signing this law is an historic and
a vital step but we must execute also
especially when the goals we set may
outlast the tenure of some of the people
setting the goals that is not to say
that I don't intend to be governor in
2050 I do but some of the other state
officials may not be around so
governments challenge is to also
implement the plan implement the plan
today that will meet those goals a
reality tomorrow and that is the art
form to develop a sustainable achievable
environmental agenda that does not
disrupt our economy but rather grows and
enhances our economy the green new
formula must first set out an ambitious
goal second develop a realistic plan to
reach that goal
third attract and incubate the
businesses that will effectuate that
economic transformation and finally
train the workforce that those
businesses will rely upon and that's
going to be the workforce of tomorrow
that is our New York agenda and that is
why our green New Deal is the real deal
my friends
today we signed the bill into into law
and we announced major steps forward in
realizing the goals set by the law in
fact we're going to take greater steps
forward today than any state has taken
to date we will lead the way in
developing the largest source of
offshore wind power in the United States
of America
[Music]
we have committed to building nine
thousand megawatts of wind power
capacity and we start today by
designating companies to build two
offshore wind farms for a combined total
of seventeen hundred megawatts of clean
[Applause]
now 1700 megawatts is enough to power
over 1 million homes for scale the
Indian Point nuclear power plant is
2,000 megawatts the first project is the
sunrise wind project it's in an offshore
area 30 miles east of Long Island it
will be developed by Oersted a Danish
company and ever source and will provide
881 880 megawatts feeding Long Island
and Long Island needs that power and it
needs it today
the second project is the empire wing
project located 14 miles southeast of
Manhattan which will be developed by
Ecuador Ecuador a norwegian company it
will develop 816 megawatts and it will
feed New York City
[Applause]
that is step number one and number two
number three is that we're going to
invest two hundred and eighty seven
million dollars to construct
manufacturing service and pork
facilities right here in the great state
of New York and Port Jefferson Brooklyn
Staten Island in the Capital Region
these projects will help make New York
the hub for this growing exciting
necessary future in
and in addition New York will provide 20
million dollars to develop a
state-of-the-art weight training program
for the most highly trained workers of
tomorrow our own State University of New
York our SUNY system will lead the
nation in this new job training
these projects will generate 3.2 billion
dollars in economic activity and
generate 1,600 construction and
permanent jobs and the projects will
have a union project labor agreement
before they come out
[Music]
and these are not just proposals they're
not just ideas we don't do that here in
New York
our agenda reflects the urgency the
agreements we signed today we'll start
moving on these projects now the port
upgrade of port upgrades will begin in
2020 construction of the onshore
facilities will begin in 2020 to
offshore construction will begin in late
2022 and the projects will be completed
by 2024
my friends today we are true to the New
York legacy to lead the way forward to
govern with vision and intelligence to
set a new standard and to match our
words with action we should all be proud
congratulations to every person in this
room from congratulations to our
environment than energy team
commissioner say ghosts and NYSERDA and
all the people who work so hard we owe a
tremendous debt of gratitude to the
people in this room for making New York
the first in the nation to lead the way
to a safer greener better sustainable
world thank you
now I have a special treat because we
owe a tremendous debt of gratitude to a
leader who not only had the vision to
see the problem on the horizon before
anyone else but he had the courage to
speak truth to power to put forth the
inconvenient truth and to dedicate his
life to fighting the status quo in the
entrenched powers which would resist and
deny the inevitable yesterday I spoke of
Robert Kennedy and Mario Cuomo
progressives in the truest meaning of
the term leaders went beyond symbolism
and shibboleths
to substance and action Al Gore is in
that progressive
I have worked with many government
officials all across the globe a small
handful have inspired me and even
smaller handful I would consider mentors
and only a couple would I consider
historic greats Vice President Al Gore
is an historic great
he truly is a leader for the ages I'm
fortunate to have served with him in the
Clinton administration I'm humbled to
call him a mentor and I'm honored to
call him a friend we all thank you
profoundly for what he has done for New
York State for America and for the world
ladies and gentlemen Vice President Al
Gore
thank you very much thank you very much
what an honor it is to be here with all
of you and with you governor this is a
historic event and I want to thank all
of those who have had a part in making
it possible starting with Governor Cuomo
about whom I will also say more in a
moment about basil sango's EC
Commissioner all of the folks with
NYSERDA all of the team members of the
governor and Dec and West NYSERDA and
the other organizations that are
involved here Thank You governor for
acknowledging the climate reality of
project Tim Ghani
[Applause]
indeed it is it's true that that we work
hard to pushing for support of this
legislation but I don't want anybody to
think for a moment that we're not keenly
aware that we were only a tiny part of a
very large coalition a number of groups
mini-album with more feet on the ground
than we have here and I want to thank
the grassroots activists here in New
York State and New York renews the
coalition that has pushed so hard for
this progress and you all did an
incredible job and I want to acknowledge
that and give you my thanks
personally I'm real proud to have my son
over here and thank you for
acknowledging him he's part of this
burgeoning clean energy sector of the
economy and I want to acknowledge with
gratitude all of the companies that have
played a role in helping to move this
transition to carbon free safe clean
energy and the sustainability revolution
that is creating so many millions of new
jobs the governor talked about all the
jobs associated with this these two
amazing projects really you combine them
together and it's the biggest offshore
wind project ever in the history of
North America quite an accomplishment
I'll come back to that in a moment we
but we've seen solar you know the Bureau
of Labor Statistics again in its most
recent report pointed out that solar
jobs are the fastest growing jobs in the
United States of America growing six
times faster than the average job growth
in the United States and this which is a
these are where the jobs of the future
are coming and
fastest-growing job is wind turbine
technician with these agreements today
they maybe I don't know I may change the
order and if indeed New York State does
become and you've got this great vision
governor over not just the transition to
clean renewable energy but also making
New York State the construction and jobs
hub for this fast-growing new industry
of the future so our transition away
from the dirty and polluting ways of the
past is absolutely essential to our
survival and for reasons well known to
all of us here it's not being led at the
federal level at all but thank goodness
it is being led by New York State and
others that have joined with the
leadership of Governor Cuomo in fact
right after the president of the current
president announced that he wanted to
pull out of the Paris agreement Governor
Cuomo took leadership immediately and
joined with former Governor Jerry Brown
and governor jay Inslee and they formed
this fantastic organization which now
represents 60% of the population of the
United States of America and when you
add in all of the cities and now
counties in the states that are not
formally part of that agreement you're
getting way on up there as a percentage
of the u.s. population that is not only
formally committed to Paris were
committed to going farther than that
agreement and of course it's always
worth reminding people that the way the
Paris agreement was written then I know
a little bit about how it was written we
can't the United under
national law under US law the first day
the US can legally withdraw happens to
be the day after the next presidential
election so there is that we have in our
hands and you may know that under the
under the terms of the agreement if
there is a new president excuse me for a
moment then a new president could just
give 30 days notice and we were right
back in that agreement in the meantime
New York states leading the way Governor
Andrew Cuomo is leading the way the
people of New York are leading the way
and God bless you there's so much at
stake I mean I'm not going to divert off
into telling you yet again how dire the
situation is but it is and by the way is
getting worse but we're gaining we're
gaining momentum I started saying we're
gaining on the crisis we're not yet at
that point but if we keep gaining
momentum we will soon be gaining on the
crisis you know the largest sovereign
wealth fund in the world norway's that
was funded hundreds in bio and gas just
announced they're completely divesting
hundred percent from oil and gas
we're seeing thanks to the business of
sector which I referred to earlier and
the engineers and the scientists we've
seen the continuing cost reduction curve
for renewable energy electric vehicles
batteries the efficiency improvements
regenerative agriculture of sustainable
forestry circular manufacturing some of
these sectors are moving faster than
others but we know what to do and we
also know that it's good for us for all
kinds of reasons it does create millions
of new jobs it does make the air easier
and healthier to breathe it does help
communities of color and communities of
the poor and disadvantaged and you know
getting rid of the burning of fossil
fuels you know one of the statistic that
jumps out at me I want to say to all the
social justice organizations that have
fought hard didn't get everything but
you are on board and god bless you for
that it is startling to me that in this
United States of America the number of
african-american children who die from
asthma is 10 times greater than the
number of Caucasian children that die
from asthma this is unacceptable and
that's only one of the statistics
[Applause]
so all around the world electricity from
projects like the one of the these two
agreements to represent is now cheaper
than electricity from burning fossil
fuels almost everywhere and soon it will
be absolutely everywhere we have seen
for the last several years for the last
nine years the global investments in
renewable energy has exceeded by an
increasing amount each year exceeded of
the investments in fossil fuels but now
something's different not only are the
vast majority of new projects solar and
wind now what we're seeing is existing
facilities being shut down long before
their predicted useful lifetimes have
expired because it's just so much
cheaper to just shut them down and
replace them with wind and solar Florida
Power and Light just announced they are
closing two of their natural gas
electricity generating plants that are
replacing them with a solar farm and a
huge battery four times larger than the
biggest battery today Pacific Gas and
Electric in California just announced
that they are shutting down a massive
natural gas generating plant with
two-thirds of its useful life time
remaini because it's just so much
cheaper now to use the Sun and the wind
so we've got this going for us and we
got the people saying we demand this and
the rising generation is demanding a
better future and what as well thank you
and we
to respond by giving them a better
future
[Applause]
this law this legislation we got the two
things you know they're both incredibly
important these agreements this is
really historic but this legislation I
want to underscore the fact that this is
the most ambitious the most well crafted
legislation in the country it is going
to in the words of some of the analysts
set a new bar there are a lot of
specialists in this area who really know
what they're talking about
one of the most respected bloggers in
this field I think he's the best but I'm
biased because he's from Tennessee
originally Dave Roberts from from the
box he wrote about this legislation
about being signed this is the most
stringent economy-wide carbon target in
the United States in one of the most
challenging states it is a new benchmark
in quote yes the 100% clean energy by
2044 T target here is the most ambitious
of any state in the country and the the
investments that will result also
including and disadvantaged and
frontline communities is also a real
step forward now on the sole thank you
it this is just a great day in my
opinion because I have to acknowledge to
you I mentioned before we're gaining
momentum the truth is some damage has
already been done we got to be candid
with people about that more will be but
we still have a chance we still have it
within our power to grab hold of this
crisis and to save the future we know
how to do we have the ability to
we need leadership we need new policies
it's it's great to change the lightbulbs
but it's much better to change the laws
we need laws and policies around the
world and if our beloved country the
United States of America is now at the
federal level in the hands of someone
who wants to push in the wrong direction
as some analysts said it's a mixture of
malevolence and incompetence and
sometimes the incompetence wins out but
if the if they're trying to push in the
wrong direction those pushing in the
right direction and helping us save the
future have to be at the state level at
the local level in the business sector
at the grassroots so what you have here
in New York say is the kind of
leadership that our country and our
world needs now finally this so these
agreements on this wind project this
this itself I've watched these all over
the world and as I said if you want the
two of them together
it's the largest new initiative of any
state in the history of the United
States and almost twice as large as any
other say supporting all the jobs that
you have heard about and now before I
conclude I want to put this also in
context this is not the first time that
Governor Andrew Cuomo has stepped
forward to provide leadership when it
was most needed
I have watched his progress as governor
I watched his initiatives as governor
and yes as he said we're friends we've
had a chance to work together we've
shared so many laughs and so many good
times I can tell you about all the
things we've laughed about together but
you would laugh too
if I did we we really have become
extremely close over the years and I
just want to say to you governor I
started saying drew I just want to say -
I'm proud to be your friend I'm proud
that you invited me once again to be
here to be present as you sign these
agreements and as you sign this
legislation you ban fracking in New York
State and I congratulate you on that
phased out phasing out cold completely
right just within a year ban on
single-use plastic bags food waste
recycle go on and on it really is an
astonishingly excellent record and I
know this the politics of New York State
is about as rough and tumble a version
of politics as you will find anywhere in
the United States
I know I know I've had personal
experience I've run four campaigns in
this state and y'all get out of each
other
just slug it out and you say no this
period has to go over here instead of
yeah okay but somehow at the end of the
day this vibrant political culture that
is so alive and well in the state yields
up and produces results that since the
days of governor Franklin Roosevelt had
even farther back have just astonished
the country at how things get done and
this governor is making this state and
this country proud and believe me this
legislation and these agreements here
today will capture the attention of
people all over the world so ladies and
gentlemen it is now my honor to join
with all of you in being a witness I
want to be a witness these agreements
and this historic legislation thank you
Andrew Cuomo
[Applause]
down in front please
down down up front please we can't see
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]